Welcome to the AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Today's Maestro Hook is about the different cultures between ghosts and scary things in Japan and in America.
Now, the very interesting thing is in America, ghosts, when you consider ghosts,...
...they are things that don't really exist in the real world.
Now in Japan, ghosts are usually people that passed away or they're your ancestors.
Freddy, Jason, and the Halloween guy, all the scary ghosts don't really exist,...
...but in Japan, a lot of ghosts are the dead, the people that died before.
So, today's Maestro Lines, today's Maestro Menu is about situations and scary situations...
...that you can use with this type of English.
Okay, the first one.
I got goose bumps.
Oh, that was scary! I got goose bumps.
And next.
I got cold sweat.
I got goose bumps.
Okay. So, a situation like Maestro Menu, Maestro Lines.
Oh, that ghost story was very scary,...
...I got goose bumps up and down my shoulders.
Cold sweat.
Oh, he almost got run over by a car!
I got cold sweat, but I'm glad he's okay.
So on a hot summer day, if you wanna hear a scary story,...
...check out Maestro Menu in AERA English TV.
Alright, see you later. Bye-bye!